nap cabs are sleeping cabins for airport
terminals in Germany that include a full
bed workspace and Internet access and
this sea slug is the first known
creature to lose its male organ after
sex and
we grow it Vsauce Kevin here this is my
second site has created the first vionic
iDevice approved for patients in the
United States the retinal prosthetic
device can restore some sight to the
blind enough to restore mobility for
example allowing patients to see the
sidewalk parked cars a table or see
someone coming through a doorway the
arcus 2 is made up of a glasses mounted
video camera a portable computer worn on
a belt and a chip implanted near the
retina the camera sends data to the
computer which converts and relays
electrical signals to the chip which
stimulates the retinal cells and right
now it costs around a hundred thousand
dollars over 80 research institutions
around Europe will use around 1.3
billion dollars in funding for the human
brain project a massive undertaking that
will use supercomputers to simulate the
human brain but first they need to
develop computers that are actually
powerful enough to perform such tasks
with the goal being to further
understand how the brain functions how
its structured how to better diagnose
and treat brain disease and how to build
neuromorphic computers which have
processors that learn like a brain what
do I look like some kind of urban
innovations genius who makes a pool out
of an old dumpster because that's who I
am
this light controlling sheep can switch
between mirror and transparent states
allowing Windows to better save energy
by shutting out sunlight electrochromic
glass itself is not new technology but
this system works much quicker without
radiating heat and they hope to use it
in vehicles and buildings Neil Freeman
redrew a map of the US with equal
population to reform electoral college
votes with each state having an average
population of six million one hundred
seventy four thousand nine hundred
and eleven tongued we know is an electro
tactile tongue display that provides an
internal sense of direction
developed at the MIT Media Lab this
inexpensive vinyl cut tongue display
allows a user to sense orientation wind
and the lightest touch and the idea is
to not only use this for the visually
impaired but also for more open-ended
sensory augmentation the Japan Society
is presenting robot theater they have a
couple of one-act plays featuring human
robot and Android actors all dealing
with life's big questions by juxtaposing
humans and robots in everyday life
finally Matthew Bugatti created a
robotic silicone tentacle with 3d powder
printing that features no hard moving
parts I'm gonna leave you with a soft
robot that jumps using explosions
so vsauce2 recently surpassed 1 million
subscribers and I just wanted to say
thanks thanks for sharing the videos
with your friends and family thanks for
being a part of the awesome Vsauce
community and as always thanks for
watching